en primer lugar Cuál es la importancia
de este telescopio Y qué lo hace
diferente al hubble
Bueno este telescopio es muy importante
porque es tres veces más grande que el
telescopio hubble en cuanto al tamaño de
su espejo y observa más hacia las
longitudes infrarrojas esto quiere decir
que nos permite observar más lejos en
distancias y al mismo tiempo nos permite
poder ver dentro de las nubes por
ejemplo donde nacen las estrellas por
todas esas cosas lo hace más potente y
nos permite ver a un galaxia más lejanas
cuéntenos Rodrigo de las imágenes que
nos ha entregado al momento el James
webb Cuál es su preferida y por qué
Bueno mi imagen son todas hermosas no
todas las imágenes que nos ha entregado
el James webb son Realmente
espectaculares Pero mis imágenes
favoritas son aquellas donde tú puedes
observar tan profundo en el cielo que de
todas estas galaxias pequeñitas que
empiezan a aparecer y las demás que
están en el fondo las que son más
pequeñas las que son más rojas son las
Galaxias de cuando el Universo se formó
y gracias al telescopio James webb
Estamos rompiendo récord y estamos
pudiendo detectar galaxias aún más lejos
o más atrás en el tiempo que cualquier
otro telescopio y en ese sentido el
James webb ha sido revolucionario y nos
va a permitir identificar en el futuro
cercano las primeras galaxias que se
formaron en el universo